hey i'm liz gillies from dynasty here
with buzzfeed to talk about my first
times
[Music]
[Applause]
first role you really wanted but didn't
get
oh okay i have a good one i auditioned
for
dark shadows and i actually
did johnny depp's voice in my audition
tape this could be why i didn't get it
and i even like octave pitched it down
and it sounded a lot like him once i saw
the movie i kind of nailed it
either i wasn't good enough which is
probably why i didn't get it or it's
because i did johnny depp's voice
reading opposite me in my audition tape
i i do really weird audition tapes first
show you ever saw on broadway
i i was lucky i went to see a good
number of broadway shows when i was
younger i saw
fosse at a very very young age but the
show that kind of rocked my world i saw
little shop of horrors and that to me
kind of solidified my obsession with
broadway
and it it just made me yearn to be
in a show and on broadway and on a stage
so i think it was little shot for me
that was my most memorable i also saw
christina
applegate and sweet charity which i told
her
when i met her first impressions
of your dynasty castmates oh my god
first impressions of my dynasty
castmates i thought raphael was really
funny
i thought grant was really serious and i
thought he was really kind of like
no no joking all work and then he kind
of opened up like a flower and became
this total
goofball that i had end up having so
much fun with and now of course he's
a really close friend of mine um adam is
a great one adam huber who plays liam
joined the show late in season one and i
had no idea what his character was or
what he was doing
or if he was gonna be here for one
episode or ten so i don't even think
i didn't even speak to him i don't think
for the first three episodes and i just
kept asking around like who is this guy
am i going to date him like why is he
here and then of course now
he's my fiancee if not husband stay
tuned on the show so
that was bad he jokes about that a lot
with me because i just kind of paid him
no mind i was like i don't know what
this character is and i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna make a new friend it's too
late in the season first memory
on the set of victorious we were filming
our opening credits music video
type thing for make it shine the theme
song and our stages were right in the
center of hollywood
and we were all just kind of dancing and
we could see the hollywood sign
and we were i just had this moment like
oh i'm in hollywood i'm on a tv show and
i was with ari and we just come from
broadway and we're like look at us
look at this we made it so it was like a
special a special first moment
first time you realized you were famous
i think i went to
a a game of my brothers a football game
or he's he was always he's an athlete so
i went to one of his games after i had
been in la and been doing victorious and
it was airing
and all these little kids started
crowding around me and wanting to talk
to me and i was stuck in one place for
like an hour and i was like i guess
i guess this is where we're at now i
guess this is the new thing first piece
of advice you'd give to your dynasty
character
fallon carrington oh my god where do i
start she's
she's a very flawed chick maybe just
to um not be just like her father i
think that's a good one because she the
more the older
she gets and the more we film with the
show i'm realizing that
she inevitably is becoming just like
blake and it happens in real life and
it's happening with her and it's it's
cool but you know
he's a tricky guy too so maybe don't be
just like your father be your own lady
she struggles with that first celebrity
crush wide range but
first celebrity crush where it was real
and i went to the book fair and i bought
a book on him that just had like fun
facts that the author probably made up
was ashton kutcher for sure
anyone my age understands what a pivotal
role he played in
you know childhoods back then he was in
every movie he was a heartthrob he was
boyish and he was tall
and he was manly yeah ashton kutcher all
the way
first victoria's castmate you text to
hang out with right now
well it's hard to say because they're
all in la and i haven't seen any of them
in a year
and a half whatever quarantine we've
been living in this house for a while
um i'd probably text ari to hang out we
text a lot
and we wish we were hanging out but
we're on different coasts so i really
miss her i hope that we can hang out
soon we need a full reunion hang soon we
were really good about doing those for
for years so we need one of those soon
first time you realized you wanted to be
a performer
i remember trying to anytime there was
an open call of any kind no matter how
fake it sounded like if i heard it on
the radio
on z100 or whatever i would make my mom
take me i just i was kind of my own
stage mom
and my mom was like my driver
facilitating my stage mom energy like i
was just
it was kind of weird but i was
determined to make something of myself
and here we are we're somewhere at least
we're somewhere first red carpet
experience
we went to we went i mean i went to like
i went to things in new york i went to
little broadway openings but my first
red carpet experience that we joke about
a lot we went to this thing called
school girls i think it was like a tv
movie i don't even remember what it was
the whole victorious cast went
and it was right when we had gotten off
media training so we were all ready to
talk about our characters and
be media trained and we sound insane in
all those interviews
and everyone looks like they're 10 years
old and i just can't stop saying these
like bizarre things about my character
as if i'm on like inside the actors
studio when it was a nickelodeon show
it's the weirdest and the pictures are
weird
and matt's hair is huge first quarantine
binge watch there was so many there were
so many what a long year
i don't know what the first one was but
obviously my most poignant was my
nashville binge watch that happened only
a few months ago i watched 125
000 million however many episodes there
were in
like a month and a half first project of
yours you'd watch again
hmm i'm really i'm really hard on myself
and so that's
that's a tough one when i was really
young i did some weird movies i did a
movie called harold
with cuba gooding jr ali sheedy and i
was like 12
and it was a really unique film made for
a little bit of money and that's a weird
one i'd watch again
or my award-winning lifetime movie
killing daddy
just gets better with every watch what a
performance given by me
not thank you buzzfeed those were my
first times you can check out the season
4 premiere of dynasty
on may 7th on the cw and then netflix
yay
[Music]
you